Did   you   miss   me?
Judging   by   the   way   the   boards   lit
up,   I'd   say   you   couldn't   live   without
me.
You   make   me   feel   so   desirable,   LA.
So   many   callers,   so   little   time.
If   you   don't   get   through   to   me
tonight,   don't   let   it   break   your   heart.
I'm   here   each   and   every   AM,   so
keep   dialing   those   magic   numbers   and   just
maybe   you'll   be   as   lucky   as   this
caller.
What's   your   name,   night   owl?
Hello,   Deb.
This   is   Greg.
Hello,   Greg.
Up   late,   aren't   we?
Well,   there,   Deb,   I   work   a   night
shift   here   at   the   power   plant   pretty
much   alone,   and   only   thing   that   gets
me   through   this   shift   is   your   pretty
little   voice.
Thank   you,   Greg.
Why,   I   imagine   if   you   was   half
as   pretty   as   your   voice,   then   you're
the   prettiest   woman   in   the   city.
Aren't   you   the   gentleman?
I   imagine   you   a   lot,   Deb.
Like   I   said,   I'm   all   by   myself
and   it   does   get   lonely.
Sometimes   a   man   can't   help   himself,   especially
when   I   hear   you.
It's   like   you're   here   straddling   my-   Greg,
there's   a   little   thing   called   too   much
information.
Caller,   you're   whiling   away   the   evening   with
the   Deb   of   Night.
Good   evening,   Deb.
Yes,   I   think   that's   implied   by   the
title   of   the   show.
[laughs]   Do   you   ever   worry,   Deb,
that   the   world   is   going   to   end?
I   haven't   felt   that   way   since   Brad
Pitt   got   married.
[laughs]   Do   you   have   any   idea   how
insignificant   you   are?
When   they   start   devouring   the   world,   you
will   be   but   a   blood   stain   on
their   capes.
I   bet   you   say   that   to   all
the   girls.
There   is   a   red   star   in   the
night   sky.
The   blood   of   mortals   and   the   blood
of   ages   all   will   be   consumed.
They   are   coming.
These   are   the   final   nights.
Okay.
Well,   good   luck   in   the   next   election,
Senator.
Apologies   to   all   you   night   owls   out
there,   but   this   girl's   got   something   she's
got   to   take   care   of   for   the
next   few   minutes.
Here's   a   little   music   to   keep   you
up,   if   you   get   my   meaning.
[horn honks]   Bill's   here,   gotta   run.
Great   breakfast,   honey.
Have   a   good   day,   dear.
I'm   glad   you   liked   the   muffins.
Hey,   what's   that   on   the   counter?
That's   not   my   margarine,   that's   butter.
It's-   [slaps]   Bitch,   you   know   I'm   supposed
to   watch   my   LDL   levels.
[cries]   I,   I   thought   it   would   be
a   nice   change.
You   couldn't   even   tell.
You   don't   want   a   divorce,   you're   trying
to   kill   me.
I'm   glad   I   slept   with   your   sister.
[door slams]   I   thought   it   was   margarine,   great
be   butter.
Other   ants   a   taste   of   margarine   with
all   the   saturated   fat   of   butter.
You   are   on   fire,   Bill.
I   finally   took   your   advice,   and   you
were   right.
I   feel   more   confident   than   ever.
You   the   man.
Isn't   it   great?
I   couldn't   even   believe   it.
We   went   out   to   dinner,   and   afterwards
we   started   getting   busy.
I   went   into   the   bathroom   to   take
it.
I   could   feel   it   right   away.
Hell,   you   could   see   the   title   change
in   the   toilet   bowl.
Vivisa   Trek,   for   when   ordinary   drug-enhanced   erection
just   isn't   enough.
Common   side   effects   include   fainting,   tingling   in
extremities,   temporary   blindness,   deathly   pallor,   time   perception
distortions,   aggravated   bladder   syndrome,   emotional   incest,   pronounced
incontinence,   delusions   of   grandeur,   and   elevated   risk
of   stroke.
Grandpa,   will   you   take   me   to   Space
Burger?
Space   Burger,   huh?
You   know,   when   I   was   your   age,
space   was   mostly   a   mystery.
We   didn't   know   what   was   up   there.
Why,   I   thought   there   were   little   alien
kids   on   Mars   that   might   be   watching
me.
Yeah,   I   used   to   make   signs   for
them   saying,   "Hello,   Martians,"   or,   "Give   me
a   ride   on   your   rocket   craft."   Of
course,   I   was   young   and   naive   thinking
Martians   could   read   English.
[laughs]   Everyone   knew   Martians   communicated   telepathically   through
space   operators   on   their   moon   base.
Billy,   what   did   I   tell   you   about
talking   to   Grandpa?
But   I   wanna   go   to   Space   Burger.
Space   Burger?
This   looks   like   a   job   for   Commander
Mom.
Report   to   the   space   van.
Oh,   boy.
We   can   drop   Grandpa   off   at   the
home   on   the   way   there.
Of   course,   you   don't   see   Martians   on
space   probes.
[laughs]   Everyone   knows   Martians   live   in   invisible
domes.
Space   Burger,   food   for   the   space   age,
not   old   age.
Last   year,   Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   bought
a   sports   utility   vehicle.
Three   months   later,   there   were   two   separate
incidences   of   hit-and-runs   by   an   unidentified   SUV
in   his   area.
Is   Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   to   blame?
Can   you   afford   to   take   that   chance?
Can   your   children?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorne,   a   candidate
that   has   never   committed   vehicular   homicide.
Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   has   never   publicly
stated   his   opinion   on   child   pornography.
Is   it   because   he's   hiding   something?
Would   you   want   a   child   pornographer   voting
on   this   nation's   laws?
Would   you   trust   your   children's   future   to
someone   like   that?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorne,   the   candidate
that   is   committed   to   locking   up   child
pornographers.
Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   recently   sued   Senator
Robert   Thorne   for   accusing   Rebens   of   being
a   murderous   child   pornographer,   but   Rebens   had
previously   said   he   was   against   clogging   up
courts   with   frivolous   lawsuits.
Wouldn't   this   make   him   a   hypocrite?
Would   you   want   a   hypocrite   as   your
next   congressman?
Would   you   want   your   children   to   become
hypocrites?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorne,   a   candidate
not   accused   of   being   a   murderous   child
pornographer.
Money   troubles?
Need   cash   quick?
Why   not   try   mugging   someone?
These   are   exactly   the   kind   of   questions
the   criminals   are   asking   themselves   right   now.
Did   you   know   that   the   government   requires
you   to   wait   ten   days   for   a
gun?
Why,   in   that   time,   a   criminal   could
kill   your   family   50   times   over.
So   how   does   a   law-abiding   citizen   like
yourself   get   a   theft-deterrent   system   in   their
hands   in   the   next   hour?
Come   to   Loophole   Lenny's.
We've   got   antique   military   weaponry   from   blunderbusses
to   World   War   I   grenades.
Modern   muggers   may   be   stronger   and   faster
than   they   used   to   be,   but   that
doesn't   mean   they   can   take   a   slug
fired   by   a   Civil   War-era   pistol   any
better.
And   if   you're   the   kind   of   person
that   can't   sleep   at   night   knowing   serial
rapists   might   be   in   your   front   yard,
we've   got   German   sniper   rifles   approved   by
the   Kaiser   himself   that'll   make   picking   them
off   one   by   one   from   the   safety
of   your   roof   no   problem.
Buy   a   weapon   this   month,   and   we'll
throw   in   an   ammo   belt   with   the
Constitution   printed   on   it   free   of   charge.
Loophole   Lenny's,   defending   your   tomorrow   with   the
weapons   of   yesterday,   today.
Ah,   would   you   look   at   this?
What's   that?
Plague   of   locusts   descend   on   small   Indian
town.
Jeez,   I   can't   imagine   what   that   must
be   like.
And   look   at   this,   civil   war   still
raging   between   ethnic   factions   in   Eastern   Europe.
Yeah,   heard   about   that.
And   in   Zimbabwe,   they   got   to   use
ox   carts   for   ambulances.
That's   terrible.
Hey,   it's   a   good   thing   we   live
in   the   US.
It   sure   is,   buddy.
Hey,   bartender,   two   more   US   ales.
US   Ale.
Welcome   to   the   United   States   of   Inebriation.